so this is one more data point Tina on
how the fed seems to be spending a lot
of time and effort but I'm not sure it's
working what it does but i also think
I'm always fascinated by how human
behavior never seems to factor into some
of these high-flown financial decisions
at all I mean greed insecurity you know
impatience these are all kind of human
factors that nobody ever seems to factor
in and I think again and again we see
that becoming a crisis financially when
people just haven't economists business
people haven't figured out into behavior
yeah I did jealousy in rivalry oh well
yes there is that crazy jealousy toxic
testosterone all of these things that
drive the market you know this is daniel
kahneman won a Nobel Prize for factoring
this into economics right but what's
amazing is when you talk to economists
his work don't want a Nobel Prize and is
deeply rooted in reality about how
people are irrational is still only
slowly finding its way into real
economic bottles the lag time here is
huge it's messy it's always humans are
messy it was a deeply messy and you know
see seeing that emotional quotient is a
huge issue and it's actually where I do
think that bringing women into that mix
is important do your ding ding no I know
that women necessarily have emotional
quotient I know plenty of women who have
none but making that diversity in the
decision-making process is critical
because that definitely impact we have
only heard about a IQ in the last few
years when you talk to headhunters they
say it's one of the top things they look
for in finding leaders for companies I
hadn't even heard of it well that's one
of those is why the wonderful Hallie
Thomas daughter who's one of my heroes
she is a woman who was leading a
financial institution in Iceland it was
the only one that didn't go belly-up
during that whole financial crisis in
Iceland because she just said wait a
minute I just don't get this this
doesn't make any sense to me and
everyone else was like charging around
you know making these terrible financial
decisions and she was gay I just don't
understand this I'm not doing it Sheila
Bair here in the US the only regulator
who said this this is insane and I'm
sure you're familiar with the research
that looks at um financial traders if
they are male if they are in the
presence of a woman they make riskier
decisions right they're showing off
their using testosterone to say look how
bold I can be with my financial
decisions right these are their real
differences in the way people act
financial and it goes beyond financial
markets and as you look inner
nationally on leadership when you have
more women in leadership in countries
the countries tend to do better they get
in fewer Wars they make better
investments they do it's interesting
Holly daughter who was just recently at
our London woman in the world summit I
mean you know she makes the point that
it's the power of three actually on on a
board for instance it's like it one
woman is a token to women is a minority
three women is a decision making a group
you know and that you have to have three
that's a whole model then where is the
disconnect talked about what you have
learned in women in the world summits
there are women who want to get
corporate board seats who want to be
CEOs of company and there's not
companies and there's not a company out
there today that will openly admit they
don't want that so why isn't it
happening yet what is the real narrative
I think well firstly I do think people
hire the people they know and so when it
comes to picking boards I do think that
the men who are obviously mostly in
charge want to be on have the people
there in the last foxhole on a deal with
so they turn to the person they were
loose last working with and or people
they know in their circle and they are
obviously predominately men so that
reinforces itself again and again and
secondly I think one of the big problems
we're now having is that this leadership
pipeline of women just isn't getting any
better really very very small gains in
that the fact is that you know so many
women are dropping out of the workforce
at the moment that it's become a huge
problem while they're dropping out of
the workforce it's because it goes back
to the child care issue it goes back to
the work-life the evil work-life balance
issue is that women just give up at a
certain point they say I cannot handle
all this with so little paid you know
family time with so little time to be
with my family I'm gonna have to make
this horrible decision then is that
corporate America's fault or is that
just life no I think actually that there
is real changes happening in corporate
America because what's become what these
companies are now beginning to
understand is it's very bad for business
to lead to lose their women leaders
you're investing all of this time all of
this money into growing women leaders
and then they disappear on you so you've
got now companies like a Vodafone for
instance interesting well this is a male
CEO and this is what I think's very
encouraging vodafone were recently
decreed of 16 weeks fully paid leave and
that they're the first kind of
multinational to have done them and they
found that recruiting and training new
employees to replace women leaving the
workforce cost forty seven billion which
is far higher
than the 28 billion of these maternity
benefits and these material benefits so
it's actually very good for business
because they keep women in the work but
then there's a social question these
companies are ready for it they want to
bring these women back are their
husbands are their spouses ready to stay
home and is society ready for that but
what I think is also interesting is you
sort of Davion outs from amazon that
they're now giving tickets sudden eight
weeks of protect paid paternity leave
for fathers which i think is a very good
thing you know in women in the world in
London we had with us the German Defense
Minister Ursula von der Leyen who's an
amazing woman she has seven children can
you believe it and she's the defence
minister so she's been very very evolved
in her career when she was labor
minister and minister of her family for
addressing these issues of work life
because she had seven kids if you can
believe it she gets labor she she's
online and she said that she chased
these maternity laws in Germany they
have one years paid maternity leave and
she also instituted two months in
addition paid paternity leave which the
men only get if they stay home when
their wife returns to work and it's just
transformed the whole attitude to men
and women and in Germany it was a very
very conservative culture where you were
called a raven mother if you left home
and went to work with your child